[Musique]
m
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture tout de suite le
sommaire le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a accueilli
les ballets de monte carlo sur scène une
cinquantaine de danseurs qui ont
revisité le célèbre conte de charles
perrault cendrillon nous avons pu
assister à la répétition générale de ce
ballet néoclassique jusqu'au 10 mai la
maison elsa triolet aragon accueille une
nouvelle exposition arles qui nahd avec
ses oeuvres composées essentiellement
d'assemblage de caisse de bois l'artiste
olga luna nous plonge dans un univers
coloré
une trentaine d'étudiants de l'ue vs qui
met à l'honneur jusqu'à début mars une
centaine de dessins de presse
il retrace l'actualité de 2010 à
aujourd'hui à travers plusieurs
thématiques la célèbre histoire de
cendrillon revisité par les ballets de
monte carlo au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la compagnie
monégasque qui a donné trois
représentations et nous avons pu
assister à la répétition générale de ce
ballet néoclassique
[Musique]
il était une fois un gentilhomme qui
épousa en secondes noces une femme la
plus hot n est la plus fière qu'on lui
jamais vu ainsi commence l'histoire de
cendrillon de charles perrault
un conte réadapter depuis 20 ans par la
célèbre compagnie des ballets de monte
carlo
un ballet néoclassique chorégraphié par
jean christophe maillot et la base de
son travail toujours du classique c'est
sûr pointe pour les mais c'est beaucoup
c'est très moderne c'est quelque chose
qui est très différent de ce qu'on
connaît habituellement et c'est ça qui
fait la force des ballets saint
christophe
c'est la cinquième fois que la compagnie
monégasque vient présenter ses balais
sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
durant deux heures une cinquantaine de
danseuses et danseurs font revivre la
célèbre histoire sur une musique de
prokofiev
sur scène tout senti vibrer rêve un
conte de fées qui propose également une
réflexion sur le souvenir des personnes
disparues
il ya toujours cependant chez jean
christophe maillot de d'avoir deux
personnages comme ça qui raconte une
histoire est effectivement la maman de
cendrillon qu'on connaît tous dans
l'histoire qui est décédé dès le début
du spectacle
et à chaque fois il ya une référence et
là on verra quand même la maman il la
ramène à d'autres à d'autres choses dans
le spectacle qui sont assez inattendu
autre différence avec le conte original
il n'y a pas de pantoufle de verre dans
cette version à la place les pieds nus
de cendrillon sont trempés dans un banc
de paillettes un détails voulus par le
chorégraphe
[Musique]
pour lui le pied de la danseuse
évidemment c'est quelque chose de
fondamental sur la silhouette sur le
l'histoire même d'une danseuse et le
fait de la plongée dans une dent de
l'étang des paillettes et de magnifier
la halle le pied c'est c'est cendrillon
fait le cloud eu l'idée de vue du ballet
un pied sans tillon qui saura séduire le
prince et le public
un ballet où l'émotion mais aussi les
sourires sont au rendez vous et qui se
termine par cette phrase bien connue
ils vécurent heureux un concours à
présent le musée de la toile de jouy et
l'association des amis du musée de la
toile de jouy viennent de lancer le prix
toile de jouy et 2020 si vous êtes
étudiants ou jeunes créateurs
professionnels et bien vous avez
jusqu'au 15 mars pour proposer votre
vision d'une nature imaginaire chaque
création sera ensuite évaluée en
fonction de sa créativité son
originalité ou encore le respect du
thème papouasie il ya plus de 30 pile
motifs différents qui sont sortis de la
manufacture tête à jouer en josas ou
xviiie siècle jusqu'au xixème siècle
d'ailleurs et donc les thèmes sont
extrêmement variés et continue
d'inspirer des décorateurs d'aujourd'hui
est donc on s'est dit pourquoi pas
lancer un concours sur le thème de la
nature retrouve figure est revisitée
mais avec une
lyon actuel de ses motifs
c'était ça l'idée et sachez que les
lauréats seront désignés le 16 mai par
le canada c'est le nom de la nouvelle
exposition visible à la maison elsa
triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines l'artiste
péruvienne olga luna y expose ses
oeuvres aux motifs géométriques et très
colorée est découverte de cette
exposition les images sont signés
mélanie peau qui depuis le 1er février
cette oeuvre inspirée du personnage de
la commedia dell'arte arlequin ont pris
place dans la salle d'exposition de la
maison elsa triolet aragon une
exposition intitulée art lucky nahd est
signée par l'artiste péruvienne olga
luna l'exposition mêle des oeuvres qui
avait été créée dans la dernière période
dans les cinq six dernières années et en
même temps toute une série d'oeuvres qui
sont des créations qui ont été réalisés
ici même à la maison elsa triolet aragon
en amont notamment à travers le biais
d'ateliers quand ont lieu avec olga mena
et qui auront lieu également pendant
toute la durée de l'exposition puisque
nous allons organiser une série
d'ateliers autour notamment de cette
question du masque couleurs contrastées
formes géométriques
l'exposition confronte des créations de
l'artiste de nature différente des
peinture en acrylique des masques en
plâtre ou encore des pliages ce qui est
intéressant aussi voyez c'est que elle
propose à travers ses pliages d'autres
regards sur les objets par exemple vous
avez la même photographique d'une
photographie de son fils en l'occurrence
et qui pliait de différentes façons mais
on a l'impression que ce sont des
photographes et qui sont différentes et
voyez ça interroge un petit peu sur ce
que c'est que l'oeuvre est ce que c'est
que le regard de celui qui regarde
durant les vacances scolaires d'hiver la
maison elsa triolet aragon propose des
ateliers de fabrication de masques pour
les enfants l'exposition elle se
poursuit jusqu'au 10 mai le dessin de
presse à l'honneur durant un mois à
l'uji excuse deux expositions sont à
découvrir dans les halls vauban et
d'alembert
elles ont lieu dans le cadre du projet
illumine projet monté par des étudiants
en master 2 de management et
communication des organisations
au total une centaine de dessins
retracent l'actualité de 2010 à
aujourd'hui
ses dessins en fait on les a cherché sur
internet
donc en fait on sait on a sélectionné un
large choix de des sang et or ensuite
refaire des sélections est en fait ce
qu'on a sélectionné du coup on a demandé
l'autorisation au dessinateur
il était vraiment très content de
pouvoir participer en fait à cette expo
est tellement content que après ils nous
ont renvoyés d'autres desseins
supplémentaire pour agrémenter
l'exposition on a été portés par une
donne donc même professeur de
communication événementielle et luce
m'endors qui est la créatrice du presse
citron et qui est aussi membre de la bnf
et celle qui a porté le projet qui nous
a aidés à le mettre en place et c'était
notre référence en fait sur le projet
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'à début
mars le 16 mai prochain l'opéra royal de
versailles fêtera ses 250 ans au
programme depuis le début de la saison
de nombreux événements lyriques le 16
mai sera notamment donné une
représentation du ballet royal de la
nuit invité dernièrement du vip laurent
bruner directeur de château de
versailles spectacles donc senti plus
dans ce ballet on retrouve beaucoup des
affrontements de l'époque le sombre
enfin je parle pas de la reine de la
nuit mais on n'y est quasiment le sombre
c'est par définition toutes les forces
du mal d'inconnues et al'inverse le
soleil soleil revient éclore c'est ce
roi peut-être aussi après la fronde
oui il ya de l'ancien frondeurs qui
danse dans le tallec
il ya vraiment une espèce de jeu de
couret et le bal a tellement de succès
qu'on donne plusieurs fois qu'on laisse
venir du public ce qui d'habitude ne se
faisait pas et il est vraiment fondateur
dans ce sens là
m
[Musique]
non
l'intégralité de l'émission est à
retrouver sur notre site
www.tv5monde.com en poste à versailles
mais on change totalement de registre
avec de l'humour à la royale factory le
duo d'humoristes et les vice versa
propose un show mêlant danse bruitages
et poésie le spectacle s'appelle
imaginer sera jouée le 21 et le 22
février à 20h30
extraits
[Musique]
non
bonjour vous avez une façon très
particulière
ok je vais ensuite
[Musique]
le 6 juin prochain aura lieu à four que
la cinquième édition de la fête de la
bière
l'organisateur pour cet événement
recherche un groupe de musique et
bavaroise pour animer donc la
manifestation de 18h à 23h
plus d'informations sur l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
on va terminer cette émission avec du
cinéma avec une sélection de films à
voir dans les salles les blinoise on
commence avec le dernier film de michel
hazanavicius le prince oubliée c'est
avec omar sy si vous êtes fan de jeux
vidéo le célèbre petit hérisson bleu
sonic débarque dans les salles obscures
autre film à voir en famille pendant les
vacances le dernier volet des aventures
de ducobu avec notamment elie semoun
enfin pour un public plus averti et
birds of prey et la fente abus les
histoires de harley quinn
voici à quelques extraits pour vous
aider à faire votre choix
chaque soir au moment de l'endormir le
pire de ce chien devient le prince d'un
monde merveilleux inventé pour elle
et chaque soir
j'arrive quartet le pinceau ou sa
princesse
jusqu'au jour où comme aux abats
l'histoire après la maison on n'est pas
seulement maintenant qui compte c'est la
fin mon pote tu vas mourir
comment tu peux être encore en vie
j'en ai pas la moindre idée
pourquoi te gâcher la vie pour ce
ridicule petit allier et mâcon c'est mon
ami vient superbe
vêtements c'est pour protéger
mais samedi ce qui est embêtant
sa mission sa potence et condamné à la
ruine son école j'ai une immense
nouvelle pour toi tu veux remporter une
jolie cagnotte pourtant d'école
est mort ce soir
inscris toi au mini conservatoire mais
chante comme une casserole mais je
triche comme un roi
ça va être la triche du siet bienvenue
dans le temple de la prix à partir de
maintenant on est les frères hodja six
chars
je te donne mes notes je te donne mes
mots auraient sauvé ducobu change
d'école ducobu va sauver saint potache
châteauroux
9 on voit qu'il a écrit
cb
ouattara
aux yeux
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour de
nouvelles idées de sorties culturelles
[Musique]